five
good evening and welcome to this
overview and scrutiny committee meeting
on thursday the 3rd of december 2020
my name is councillor vanessa bell and i
am the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect
on the 4th of april in response to the
kovic 19 situation and there are just a
few housekeeping issues to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted
and your video feed off when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
apologies for a moment
sorry
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
please do not use the raised hand
function as this is not available on all
member devices
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
and last if members need to leave the
meeting at any point
please do make this known and use the
chat function to signify that you need
to leave the meeting
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
please
starting with ms hughes
good evening members cheryl hughes
programs performance and governance
manager
thank you msu's
good afternoon members bernie casey talk
to the committee
thank you chairman thank you berna i
don't believe there are other any
any other officers present are there
berna no chairman
thank you bernie could you please now
carry out to carry out
a roll call of members to confirm who is
in attendance
thank you chairman members i'll call
your names in alphabetical order
please indicate that you're in
attendance starting with councillor bell
presents good evening everyone pastor
beale
president thank you councillor passenger
good evening everyone i'm thank you
councillor boyce
councillor boyce
okay councilman maize
good evening president thank you thank
you
councilman morris good evening and
welcome
thank you thank you chairman
thank you may i have the apologies for
absence please berna
yes chairman we've received apologies
for absence from councillors duik
and fleming thank you very much berna
okay moving on to item two which is the
minutes of the 15th of october 2020
meeting
it's recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 15th of october 2020
found on pages 7 to 10 are approved as a
true
and accurate record iso move if you wish
to second that motion
please turn on your video unmute your
microphone and state your name now
councilman base i'll second that
thank you councillor maze if any member
wishes to raise a meta
many matter of accuracy please use the
chat function to indicate
and i will invite you to speak
[Applause]
i believe we have councillor heard
um
yes thank you um just uh just letting
you know that that i am here thank you
okay thank you very much councillor
heard good evening
it's good to have you here uh sorry
chairman um
i forgot to ask for members in
attendance to introduce themselves after
i did the roll call and i believe we do
have some
apologies for that oversight um i
probably should we do that now
yes please any members in attendance if
they could introduce themselves now
before we continue
uh yeah and uh councillor schemes is
here
thank you anybody else in attendance
yeah i'm hick they're
lovely thank you very much apologies
again chairman
no problem it's all burner no worries um
right i believe we were on matters of
accuracy
from the minutes and i don't think there
were anywhere there
uh no chairman nobody's indicated all
right
okay lovely um now we'll take the vote
or are we able to uh approve by
ascent uh yes if there's no dissent uh
the commission can approve by ascent
right
approved approved
approved thank you very much members
on to public participation item three
um mr chairman could i yes could i
interrupt um
counselor you can call me miss chairman
councillor mays but not if you call me
mr chairman
mr chairman yes
go ahead um yeah councillor
heard raised his hand i'm sorry
councillor heard i thought we had
um i can't see any hand up
so okay um sorry sorry chairman it's
just that
uh at the very time i was meant to
introduce myself
um it i just certainly uh lost
connections so just to let you know
that i'm here i'm sorry to labour the
point um we did get you counsellor heard
but we're still very glad you're here so
much thank you
thank you for that thank you
okay and chairman sorry cousin morris
has indicated he
has a question so just in case it's on
the minutes before we move on
yes thank you very much burner
councillor morris please
thank you chair i would just like to
congratulate you of uh
for for getting the role um and i'd also
just like to
ask i'm a little bit uncertain have we
got a member of the democratic
alliance group in tonight is councillor
boyce here
let's count here if we got anyone from
the
from the democratic alliance group here
i believe not is that right so boyce is
the
is the member and he's he's not here
tonight
oh i thought with it councillor
yes cancer dueck is part of the
democratic alliance as well but uh sorry
he's just given
um apologies for a number of other
meetings so i
had it i just wanted to confirm if there
were any democratic
alliance group members here and they're
on which is
a bit sad thank you thank you very much
councillor morris um
right where were we i think we'd agreed
the minutes without any uh
matters of accuracy which um we then
we've moved on to public participation
sorry
and we haven't received any submissions
berna have way
no jenna no thank you okay then
moving on to item four which is
declarations of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests or other pecuniary
interests
or non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive
of the code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the news arrive through arise
throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat function now
to indicate and i will invite you to
speak
i assume from the deafening silence that
there are no work declarations of
interest
thank you very much members
moving on then to agenda item number
five
working group of the committee now this
is found on pages
11 to 12. and in a moment i will call on
the officer to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak please make this known by using
the chat function within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn and
please keep your points clear and
concise
so ms hughes please can i hand over to
you to present the report
yep no problem uh good evening
members so this report deals with
appointing to the working group of the
committee
uh the working group are responsible for
reviewing scrutiny items that have been
put forward
by members as to their validity for the
committee work plan and reporting this
back to the committee with
recommendations
reviewing watching brief items and
reporting back to the committee where
relevant
and supporting the planning of overview
and scrutiny work
the committee agreed to these terms of
reference for the working group on the
15th of october
and although working groups are not
politically balanced a request was made
after the terms were agreed to make the
working group politically balanced
the report includes the information
should we members wish to appoint in
this way
and that's two independent councillors
one conservative councillor
and one democratic alliance member um to
make up the numbers
thank you thank you very much
gerald so um does any member wish to
second that motion
if they do so please turn on your video
now and i'll meet you unmute your
microphone
counselor maze i'll second that
thank you very much councillor maze
thank you
so um now i will invite members to make
any comments
on the report so i believe this is where
we
um where we elect members is it
berna yes this is the point where we
deal with the nominations
thank you morris has a point he wishes
to raise
chairman and chairman i think your
camera is off i
don't know maybe you've just lost sorry
take the technical hitch
yes no problem thank you
i do apologize members technical hitch
council
morris
thank you joe um i'd just like to know
how
this uh will all won't work this evening
because we have no
representatives from the democratic
alliance group
we have no um
attendance from any of the democratic
alliance group
uh given the um absolute abysmal
attendance record of one of those
members um
can we uh can we do this properly can we
do this democratically
um should this not be deferred uh you
know i'd invite
other members to uh give their opinions
over
um it seems that you know if we have no
one from
that political group here we might well
um
not be able to uh fulfill the duties of
the committee
thank you thank you very much um
councillor maurice if i could just
check first of all ms hughes is there
any guidance on this
uh yeah so um obviously with um no
democratic alliance members present
it wouldn't be proper to nominate any of
them to the seats because we wouldn't
know if they'd want it or not
so you've got two options you can
appoint to three seats
um leave the fourth seat empty and then
the working group can still sit because
it will be correct
or you can choose not to make the
working group politically balanced and
just appoint members based on
who you'd like to appoint from the
committee and because as i said it's not
actually part of the terms of the
committee it's just that the committee
had asked for it to be politically
balanced
thank you very very much for that that's
really helpful so
um members i would like to pass some
this over to you for a discussion then
what what are your views please
chairman cancer maze has her hand raised
that's the maze
sorry i didn't see you counselor most
uh no sorry that was from earlier
however um
i i do believe that we should um
take this forward um and appoint three
seats out of four
um and leave the one seat empty thank
you
okay thank you i've got councillor
morris then councillor heard
please councilman
just stole my thunder thank you thank
you councillor maurice
please is it councillor heard next
yes thank you chairman and thank you for
allowing me to speak at uh at this
meeting
um actually i was really just going to
suggest
that which has just been done um because
i i know that
uh councillor helm as past
chairman of this committee i'm i'm sure
would be interested in that position
so i think it would be um it would be
the right thing to do to hold that open
thank you very much council i heard my
cats the helm isn't on this country
no that's cancer duik and councillor
boyce
yes oh okay i do apologize
i i'm wondering as i'm wondering also
whether i'm also very aware that we only
have one um
conservative representative here tonight
councillor morley
so would it be right and proper to uh
elect for that seat either
members what what are your views
yes
if council whole is here and they
substitute
um no counselor maurice um she is not
we have um unfortunately we have no
substitute for it
you're in attendance you're not here as
a substitute for any other conservative
member so
that's different thank you unfortunately
um a substitute wasn't available for
this evening's meeting sadly
so counselor molly what's your view yeah
well well
i think leave it clear i i wasn't i
actually thought um
council fleming was going to be in
attendance but um
i haven't heard anything yet so uh
i'd imagine just just leave it vacant
for now
as um councillor morris was saying
thank you right okay so then this i
believe
is oh now i'll need guidance with this
misuse please but um so the proposed way
forward appears to be to nominate to the
independent um
right yes i've just been advised thank
you that we also have an issue with the
um with appointing to the working group
um sorry counselor morris
sorry i'll come back to you mrs hughes
councillor morris
i'd suggest that we uh propose that we
defer this
thank you the problem yeah the
difficulty
is that we were due to sit next week
however
if we cannot have if we cannot have the
group
elected democratically then um then we
can't
do that and if we do nominate tonight
to the um to the two uh
independent seats then we'll only have
to revisit we still won't be
um miss hughes would we be correct for
the working group if we did that
yeah you would be cora i suppose the
issue is that if you only appoint
two seats now um would the two members
be comfortable doing the business
um because obviously the working group
was due to meet next week
to be able to report back to the next
committee
um so i i suppose really it's about
um you know do we want to proceed um or
that might hold up the next committee
meeting being held
because the working group wouldn't have
sat which means we can't hold the next
committee meeting in time
um or do you want to appoint um just not
politically balanced
that's the question for the committee
really thank you
councillor mays
councilman
uh yes sorry uh chair um
i i do feel that um
we should try and make this um
politically balanced
it's not an ideal situation that we find
ourselves in
however i think we need to move forward
um a point whom we can
um and obviously we will then have to
look at
uh appointing to the other seats um at a
later time
thank you um councillor morris please
thank you chair um giving it due
consideration
um i do think that we perhaps should
just uh
jump in the deep end we all knew that we
were supposed to be here
um no one from the democratic alliance
group has turned up
uh one conservative member has turned up
we all knew we're supposed to be
um there are a few of us here that
attend
all the meetings and um you know if
you're not
if you're not ready to play you
shouldn't be on the pitch so perhaps we
should just push forward
so that we can get the council's
transactions
completed thank you thank you um
members i am i am inclined to agree with
um with councillor morris
council amazes your hand up again or is
that from previously thank you
so any any other members have
uh have an opinion we need we do need to
move forward and councillor morris does
make a very valid point about attendance
so um
yes yes you may counselor morris please
do
so chairman council bastard yeah sorry
counselor passenger first then council
yeah sorry madden chairman i'm trying to
my technical
things not working at the moment but uh
if it helps i
i would be prepared to um come on to the
working group
in the place of one the democratic
alliance
if it helps thank you thank you very
much councillor messenger
um councillor morris
oh i believe
yeah i propose that we uh make the
working group up
and that it cannot be politically
balanced due to the
lack of attendance and engagement by the
uh
other um political groups so that is my
proposal
um if anyone would like to second that
do i have a second counsellor maze
i will second that and i totally agree
we did all know about this meeting
um and yes i agree with the sentiments
exactly thank you
thank you very much councillor mays so
um
can we vote on that please can we do
that by sentence or do we need to take a
vote members
we so
you've agreed we've agreed that proposal
to move forward
have we agreed that it's been proposed
and seconded
agreed agreed agreed agreed
marvelous thank you members okay then
moving forward
um i would like to propose
counselling maize for the working group
do i have a seconder
agreed
thank you i think that was a cent there
was it can i have a
yeah thank you
any other members
councilor mays uh yeah
um i would like to propose councillor
bell yourself
um as chair for this group please
if i have a seconder and i'll i would
like to second that if i may
thank you councillor passenger is that
agreed by ascent members
agreed thank you agree thank you
thank you um members i would like to
um nominate sir a councilman morris
then as he is a regular attendee of all
meetings
and um yes i would like to propose him
do i have a secondary
yes i'll second that okay
agreed members agreed
we agreed agreed
um councillor heard wishes to speak i'm
sorry i'm not sure
i forgot previously that you aren't
actually a member of this
uh committee and i forget the rules i'm
speaking i believe it's okay if you do
and i'm pushing my luck chairman by
asking to speak once again
um but i'm just perhaps hoping that you
may leave
as long as you're correct as you can
leave one place vacant
um and then that will at least allow one
other person to come on there
thank you um i believe
that counts as what we agreed does it
not
um assistance please officers and then
i'll come to you councillor maze
thank you
so you feel sorry carry on would that
leave
uh would that be contrary to what we've
just agreed
i i think what you agreed was just that
you weren't going to make the committee
uh the working group politically
balanced so
if you left one open you it still
wouldn't be politically balanced
so really i mean i i do believe
that we should have a conservative
member on this group
and i don't want to put counsellor molly
under pressure to feel that he has to
volunteer himself
well if it helps it looks like i'm going
to have to doesn't it
so yeah um that's entirely up to you
cancer morning if you wish to defer
it and have a conversation with
councillor um
fleming prior to the next meeting that
is an option that you have
is it an option and that's fine if we
can do that that's fine
you know i believe we can i believe we
can do that
i mean i'm easy so uh
thank you um ms hughes could you please
uh advise
on that whether that is an acceptable
way forward we have a corporate working
group
yeah so you can just allocate one place
to the conservative
group um the working group can meet
obviously means the conservatives won't
be able to join in this time but then
we can bring back their proposal for the
next meeting
i think that answers some i think that
answers our
our queries doesn't it really i think
councillor mays you
have a i'm actually i i really feel that
counselor morley should be
um on this group he is in attendance
um and i think that his views would be
would be valued
and as a conservative i think that is a
and i propose that
councillor morley um is asked to uh
be a representative on this particular
committee thank you
thank you councilman that's the morley
how do you feel about that
i'm flattered do i have a second uh
does councilman mayes have a seconder
i i would like to second that madam
chairman if i may thank you mate
thank you thank you very much so um
that's councillor morley you um you are
i believe do we assume we agree with
that members
agree i said thank you
um berna i believe we do have our
committee now do we yes you do chairman
we do thank you very very much so
moving on to item six which is the
update on the overview and scrutiny
process
implementation so that's on pages 13 to
14
and in a moment i will call on the
officer to present this item
but i'm just going to give you a quick
reminder if you wish to speak please
make this known by using the chat
function
and i will come to you in turn please
again
keep your points clear and concise thank
you miss hughes if i can hand over to
you please
thank you chair okay so this report
gives an update on the implementation of
the agreed working process that was
brought to the 15th of october committee
and following agreement of the ons
agenda minutes at the 5th of november
council
an online form has now been created and
circulated to members
so should they feel they have an item
for overview and scrutiny
and they can put something forwards for
the working group to consider
as things stand we haven't yet received
any
um preparation for the first working
group meeting
to start start off work planning for the
committee has taken place
this meeting will need to happen shortly
after this committee to allow for
reporting deadlines
and i'll be in touch with appointed
members shortly to arrange this
the intention is that the working group
meetings will then provide
a standing item report to be reviewed at
the committee
and so this report seeks feedback from
committee members on the process
so far and suggestions for moving
forwards to be factored in
thank you thank you very much for that
um
misuse thank you so um the
recommendation set out in the report
is oh no am i on the right
um sorry i do apologize i've whizzed
forward
so i will now invite members
to um well i'm on that yes
the recommendation sorry is that members
review and feedback on the information
provided and i'll now invite members to
make any comments
on the report so bernard has anyone wish
to speak please
nobody's indicated as yet chairman
nobody's indicated that they wish to
speak
no okay so um
well i recommend that the um as
counselor passengers just come on camera
that's the passenger
go ahead please sorry madam chairman i
would go through the chat thing but
it isn't working so don't worry i i just
uh have a loose question if i may
through you um
to the officer um the the form is it
is it will we know where to send this
form
is it does that go back to the committee
chairman
where does it go so
it's an online link that comes through
me and then
i will bring a report to the working
group to consider of any reports that
we've had in
and so that's why we've got the um and
the mechanism that was agreed in the
october committee meeting
um was that those forms come in the
working group review them and then
recommend whether they're an item that
should be taken forward or not
and that report of the working group is
what comes back to the committee
um um for approval as to instigating an
overview and scrutiny item
great so so just basically it's a very
simple process we just fill in the form
send and and the rest is
okay thank you very much thank you madam
chairman thank you
um i i have counselor morris but just
first can i just
some say that the uh i believe misused
that on the uh
agenda for the working group meeting is
how we are going to publicize and make
this as widely available to members as
possible
so we're not sitting on this this will
be
we will be looking at how we can
disseminate this
and raise awareness to the max about
this process
so i hope that helps councillor morris
thank you chad i'd just like to um
impress that i do believe that we need
to make the procedure secondary
to any item and that hopefully the
procedure
wouldn't supersede any item that came in
you know if the fall wasn't filled
in if the film didn't get to the right
place i would like to just get the
reassurance that
you know that the item um would get to
be heard by hook or by crook
and not reliant solely on an online form
that you know could have problems thank
you
um can i just clarify councillor morris
um that you are talking about you know
excel i can't say it accessibility
so anybody who had issues or
difficulties in any way shape or form
in completing the online form would be
assisted to
to make a submission in an alternative
more accessible manner is that what
you're asking
yes chair yes i just wouldn't want the
situation to arise
where a uh you know an important item
was brought before us
and due to it not being um procedurally
correct
in the form you know because someone um
didn't get the formula on time or
something like that i'd hate the
procedure
to dictate um you know whether or not
the item was heard it should be
the content of the item um for first and
foremost
and i just like that reassurance from
officers
thank you miss yo's please but all
member suggestions so say somebody did
it by email
instead of the form all members
suggestions for overview and scrutiny
item
would be put forward to the working
group to consider whether or not it was
a genuine
overview and scrutiny item to bring back
to the committee
thank you very much miss hughes council
maurice does that answer your
question that's great thank you very
much
thank you amazing counselor passenger
thank you councilman can i come to you
first
yeah thank you um chair um
it sounds like a very simple um system
how will members know if their item
is to bit is to be forwarded to overview
and scrutiny
for for for scrutinization
uh will something go back to that member
to say that it's going to be put forward
or it isn't going to be put forward
because of
it doesn't fit the criteria or whatever
then there needs to be some sort of
mechanism
thank you thank you councillor maismus
hughes can i come to you for that please
yeah so we've built into the process and
when a member submits a form it says we
will
respond to you once the working group
have sat to confirm what the working
group have decided
um perfect yeah thank you
thank you councillor bassinger
thank you um just just another thing
just to pick up from one of the points
that council morris made and
that's regarding the time frame is there
a sort of
cut off point i mean you know is it sort
of two days before or three days
because again i wouldn't like a an item
not to be reviewed
just because we've run out of time or it
didn't reach you in time so is
is that quite clear as well what the
time frame is
this huge if i could come to you again
yeah so it's not
set with any time limits um basically a
member
completes a form and then that's a
request for an overview and scrutiny
items so that means the working group
needs to sit
and review that overview and scrutiny
item and so basically kind of that
process kicks off the requirement for
the overview and scrutiny
working group to review it
okay thank you thank you does that
answer your question thank you very much
um members i don't see any other hands
up
so um if everybody has spoken who wishes
to
uh do we need to take a vote or can we
agree this
um by sense please
agreed lovely thank you very much so
that does now take us on to uh agenda
item number seven which is appointment
of representatives on liaison committees
which you'll find on pages 15 and 16.
so i will
hold on sorry yeah bear with me
so i will shortly go to um miss hughes
for this but again the reminder if you
wish to speak
please use the chat function and i will
come to you and please
keep your points clear and concise thank
you
so miss hughes it's like a game of
ping-pong over to you again
okay so um members we've got one seat
available
on this liaison committee at essex
county council
and the paper seeks appointment although
this was previously appointed to the
chair
any committee member can be nominated to
the seats
um so the paper really deals with
calling for
a nomination for that position thank you
thank you very much miss hughes i
think um now any members uh wish to
speak
yes customers councillor maze i thought
i saw your hand up thank you
yes thank you chair um i would like to
nominate councillor beale
um to this working group please
do i have a second uh yes i will second
that um
councillor maze thank you do we have
any other nominations for this working
group please members
the silence suggests no so can we agree
councillor brian b or by a cent
please members agreed i agree a grade
agreed that's lovely thank you very very
much so just to add that is
for the remainder of the municipal year
which is
to may 2020.
21 21 what am i talking about
who wants to relive this year again
frankly quite enough so
members thank you very much i do believe
as
under item 8 that i have no other items
of business that i decide i've decided
are urgent
that it's now time to close the meeting
so
thank you all very very much for your
contributions this evening
and i now draw the meeting to a close
at 18 36.